let me say something too I want to ask
you a question you I'm never going to
blurt out personal [__] about you yeah
cuz I know so much oh I know right look
at me right now you can't even look at
look at me right now yeah I know some
things I know I know some things about
you right that are pretty disturbing
yeah I mean and every time I see you you
go don't talk about my stuff on your
podcast right I would never do it I
would never do it but why can't I
um I don't want to go to jail
wa no that's tough that's tough that's
tough I don't want to go to jail yeah
you're not going to go to jail I don't
want I don't think that anything you've
done warrants jail I think that's a
little but are we allowed to talk about
what what your brother has forced you to
do no yeah that's yeah well I don't know
yeah it's yeah yeah yeah oh see see
you're worried about that me yeah I'm
not worried about
it well well I had I had I had laan over
can you Reve okay can you reveal that
then okay well cuz laan it's already
going to be out there cuz he's it's
already going to go out there well well
we didn't specify but so when's the last
time you spoke to laan 10 years who is
La there's a guy laan Fus let me do it
he's a pro skater he's a pro skater he
skated for dog town and laan was the
first guy to when I when I was using
drugs to give me an intervention he's a
really good dude I love that guy yeah
he's a great guy he yeah I had seen him
in like has a photograph wait hold up
are you you going right
there oh you want to build it well I
talked about it he's a host now well
lean's the first guy he picked me up
from the airport when you first came to
La when I first came to La he was there
during the dumpster days no but the
remember the first time you visited me
and I didn't pick you up nobody picked
you up oh can we talk about that well
nothing happened he left you strand at
the airport I was stranded at the
airport where was I I don't know I was
in Vegas that's when you live with
shamama yeah and he had like [__] 10
cats I got dude I almost died like my
immune system broke oh cuz you were
allergic before well sheam had a bunch
of cats I hated him so anyway back to
the photo yeah so anyway yeah laan was
there when I first moved to LA when we
lived on uh you know in Silver Lake ech
Park area and uh yeah man he was your
best friend yeah I love him but uh he
did something what did he
do what do you and I do I don't know I
think
one one night I stuck
a it had to do with your butthole in a
Snickers bar
the just get directly
into what it is is
this you no you stuck a sck in your but
you took a Snickers bar and you stuck in
my [__] well you willingly cuz you
wanted him to I don't know we did yeah
wow guys the thing is I didn't know I
didn't know what that laan was there and
um when he took the picture my face was
so you were inserting it like by B yeah
and laan took a picture of it yeah so
I'm like this like this and he uh Bob
had a big birthday party at the
Spaghetti Factory I used to have okay so
my that there used to be a yeah there
used to be a Spaghetti Factory on Sunset
Boulevard and I used to do my birthday
parties there and they used to be the
best I'm not kidding you I mean you know
menia paully Shore you know my TV people
and then those comics and skaters and it
was a dinner and and so my brother and I
sitting there at this pretty know what
was 60 70 people there and me dude your
manager management was there yeah Abby
was there yeah Abby was everyone yeah my
agent everything and so what laan did he
made multiple copies Xerox copies of my
face of my face with the Snickers bar in
his butthole and you can see Bob's nut
sack and I I was like this he sticking
it in his butle and uh he passed it
around um no it's not it was basically
everyone that came to the party got one
oh welcome to the welcome to the party
right which I didn't it's like a grab
bag yeah but Bobby Le grab and then what
well it ruined I don't know if you
remember I was close to dating someone
named Rose yeah and that and she
afterwards she she came up to me and
what' she say why did you do
it why
did why did she wait why did she look at
you like you killed a yeah why did you
do it why did you do it Steve why and
then she was like shaking oh my God so
late so I eat
Unisom yeah and what the Unisom does it
it makes me horny mhm you talked about
this right and then what I do is I will
why you looking at me like that oh no I
just start zoned
out I don't know I don't know I was
daydreaming I was like are you listening
to what I'm saying yeah yeah he's
thinking about he's thinking about the
do no I'm not I'll repeat you take
Unisom and when you take the Unisom it
gets you horny for some reason it does
for some reason okay so I'm listen have
you ever taken unome yeah does it get
you horny
yes absolutely I know that about you
yeah yeah
about the same DNA right and you take
the massager right and you just gently
don't push it on there right and you
watch porn and it you know I've done
that just on the head yeah not on the
shaft at all sometimes on the shaft yeah
and if you hit it right it's like but
you know there is such a thing that
women have to be careful with um getting
VI we have to be careful with vibrator
um desens desensi desensitize getting
desensitized by vibrator so it's
actually not good for us to always use a
vibrator because a dick can never
compare afterwards and we can't we can't
orgasm from kius alone when we if we're
so used to the strong vibrations of a
vibrator what on your clitoris yeah
because nothing compares it's the best
feeling in the world kala I want you to
ask my brother anything about the
country who people are govern I don't
know what's going on with Trump if he
doesn't choose to know it then that's
probably I just turned the othere can I
ask you a George can ask you a simple
question yeah who's the vice
president no no who's no being I'm being
real who's the vice president of the
United States uh
Robert do you really don't know Robert
El I don't even
know yeah
Benson Benson Henderson bon bon
Henderson Bon the Black Butler from the
show Benson Clifford Benson Clifford not
Clifford that's it that's it I can't you
got it you got it right on how do you
know Clifford
Benson what was that right yeah yes it's
no
it's Clifford penson what's going on
yeah our vice president is named Mike
Pence Mike Pence okay shout out to Mike
Pence you're doing a good job not not
okay you're not doing a good job I don't
watch anything I don't know I mean so um
we took this test earlier yeah we test
took a test earlier tell tell 1% of the
population are called super recognizers
meaning to say that they can discern
different faces and different facial um
um um what do you call it traits very
very well and there's 1% of the
population called like what's it called
indigenous they're they're basically
face blind uhhuh and so they can't even
recognize um their own face sometimes
and they're very bad with like
distinguishing like I brought it up
because I went to work today and one of
my bosses has that disease oh yeah it's
called propag noia propag noia propos
wait what is it again so
basically let me just say this right now
no no stop for a second okay let me just
say this right now here goes what he
just did baby what did he do for the
last two minutes he tuned out he tuned
he completely tuned out dare of the
whole thing I Ted out and and now Hees
know what the [__] we're talking no no
the thing is I my mind was I was still
on the atom thing like God damn stilling
like why did I bring that up yeah and
I'm thinking all the editing and all
this stuff and I'm like and then you
guys are talking about an app okay can I
try to re like just um regurgitate what
you just said yeah there is an app out
there you're right keep keep going keep
going keep going keep going keep going
keep going what did we just say go ahead
there's an app out there there's an app
yeah that it could recognize it's it's a
fa facial recognition app yes and so
it's for people yeah um help me out Jo
no okay hold up okay there is an app out
there hear me out hear me out what you
just said there's an app yeah and it's
for people who can't recognize faces
they'll meet someone and be like I don't
recognize I and then when they go back
to meet them they go who the hell is
that and then they go to the app and
they go to the app and they go it's
Frank no no no there's an app that has a
test in it w so there's a test and then
it's like a maybe a 10 to 20 question
it's like a more of like a 50 question
thing and then it you kind of um you it
just goes through like your you know
your memorization memorizing testing
about memorizing yeah memorizing faces
and stuff so that you can start getting
better at it yeah so you get better at
it you know cuz it's like repeti nothing
to do and everything it has nothing to
do what we were talking about my friend
all right let's start from the top I'm
I'm going to listen now watch so there's
a disease called propag noia proposa
where people cannot recognize familiar
faces
okay so even if I've seen you 50 times
when I see you again I still don't know
who you are right I've met people like
that oh really so 1% of well I don't
can't say their name but like you know
I've met them before like at a meeting
and they'll go what's your name again
maybe you're not memorable oh my god wow
is your chest okay no I'll be honest
with you like cly thought that I had it
it's just that cuz some people that I
you know I I I meet a lot of her friends
even a lot of comics come up to me and
go and I just don't they're not that
memorable yeah I me at first if you're
not paying attention either you and I
don't pay people don't pay attention in
the a meeting noia propag okay so
there's 1% of people who are face blind
that's propag noia and there's 1% maybe
I haven't met any I'm sorry I take that
back they're probably are if it's 1% of
the population that's a lot cu no I know
like once I said that I was open
to you confuse that with just forgetting
people's names wow once I said that I
was open for ridicule and so I just I
ridiculed you a little bit you know oh
you were mad when I said that yeah a
little bit cuz I'm a I mean I'm I'm not
a ghost I'm not saying I'm like a you
know popular but I'm not a ghost you're
pretty popular no no not in the larger
scheme of things and like maybe little
pockets of society I am but not compared
larger scheme I'm not wow I really
offended you huh did you see it my face
a little bit I anger what you were
talking about what it is is this yeah
he'll say something it's like and then
I'll do a little tick I'll go in my mind
it's like it's like when it's like when
um um what's Hulk Hogan's Alter Ego not
Hulk Hogan Incredible Hulk Bruce ban
Bruce ban it's like Bruce Banner's pants
ripping a little
yeah jean shorts and you go oh don't get
him more mad and then he calms down yeah
yeah and then then the you know but I
haven't done that in a long time you
just did it no you mean full rage not
full rage but you a little your pants
split a little bit I'm sorry okay let's
go back to okay no can I just say this
too when I went out before you when you
were in the um living room and I was
doing the dick dance with my pants down
yeah why you said something about my pis
Steve said hey Bob do it again I think
it's shink uh
shrinking you think so your tick
shun wow those are fighting words bro
fighting words
dogun he asked Bobby he asked Bobby did
four times it's
like
it t like
this it looks like a bird piece it looks
like a bird piece of beef
jery there there's more hair than there
is
skin it's just a a
bush it's like a
bush
this oh my God the size of my pig
oh god oh you're going to make me die I
don't know you brother you got start
working out you got just start doing
something
you about
you I'm so
worried he's worried about
me oh stop stop stop stop stop stop okay
oh oh man oh man oh man oh D do I'm not
his bush is just really long long right
now why really long like he hasn't he
hasn't yeah he doesn't shave you shave
it I used to shave remember yeah yeah
yeah he doesn't do that anymore H so so
go look CH so he was trying to show me
this like America America's Got Talent
video when I got home from Vegas but one
one of the only open it was YouTube tab
open and the other tab I was like what
is that it's o l d j and that's what
that's what I found
Steve what the [__] Bobby he likes the
old guy [__] Bobby what Steve look look
at this Bobby Bobby I you it's an old
guy with a you should be on there this
is a six-year-old or Armenian guy with a
boner he been abused I'm telling you he
hit perfect with those guys wait his
body dick size yeah yeah he's you're
perfect with those look at that his body
dick side look at that guy you know what
with him he's a sick [__]
he he gets off more on the men than the
women do whoa whoa whoa whoa what do you
mean no no no not that you're attracted
to the men no I'm not attracted to the
men but I look here's what it here's
what it is you're like damn this old
[__] this little girl I know but
here's what it is [__] you know how you
can when you see a porn you can click on
like you can see more videos of Sabrina
right the girl right and then you press
it and there's like 20 all all her her
like work videos yeah I don't do that
one the I do Walter oh oh you click the
guy I pick the guy see who he's worked
with yeah who he's worked with because
Walter's killing the game nothing
happened you think I [__] you up with
porn I'll talk let's talk about the goth
chick okay so I met her at um Greco's
Pizza why your stories yeah so you met
her at Greco's Pizza um Greco's Pizza
Greco's Pizza it was after the clubs
like St we used to go to Star shoes and
drink M uhhuh and I was with one of my
friends I forgot who it was and I
noticed a like a a fatter pale goth
chick kind of like talking to herself
like yeah [__] oh my God I know and
then and then she started like listening
to our
conversation and so I
go I don't know what happened I invited
invited her
back and uh I don't know what happened
so I invited her back well I well I
don't I I don't know what happened of
like how she got closer to our table
Yeah but she'd like start listening to
our conversation yeah and I go hey what
you live around here what's going on oh
my God and she goes
[Music]
yeah I'm like well we're going to drink
some more beers back am I I always use
that line hey we got more beers back at
my little shoe box apartment or whatever
yeah and I love your pickup line yeah
that's like hey we got some more beers
back here yeah so somehow she ended up
back there right and uh you met her
didn't you I was angry with you yeah and
then I I just remember one of the
nights I found out later she was didn't
have a place to stay oh she was with you
for a few days and she was lit no no
yeah that one night or maybe a day
couple nights couple nights cuz I came
over I came nothing happened though came
of course you know why because because
she she is a schizophrenic but no not
only that she got caught up with the
Church of Satan she start telling me
[__] she was like um the the the head of
the Church of Satan communicates me
through his mind she's schizophren so I
go oh and then she said and you wanted
to [__] her well I was so desperate back
then you know yeah was really desperate
back then really yeah let's edit this
out I have a question for you
okay so one night let me finish my if
you wanted edit it why you keep talking
well I was I'm too deep down this Rabbit
Hole I'm already like a half a mile in
James Jam talk about James talk about
James so James so James said she uh was
sleeping at on the sleeping bag on the
ground and I go hey I won't you come up
here it's more comfortable up here and
and then so she I got her up up on the
bed and she was still like James did
James did James got her on the bed yeah
and she was still in her goth outfit and
James tried to do the a side thing
cuddle C but then she did the whole
tortilla wrap with the blanket like she
wrapped yeah she wrapped her whole body
in it so that nothing happened with me
and her so yeah yeah thank God yeah
imagine would you have used a condom of
course I have I have another story of
like this Russian lady that I met tell
me that story so I met I was like
heading to the bars this is this is all
when I'm not sober so just to clarify
okay to the my clean and sober I'm sober
this is over eight years ago okay so me
and my buddy uh Ace uh we're heading up
we used to drink at uh the uh Kodak
Theater this place called cois right
happy hour had $2 sauro I remember Co
yeah they had like happy hour cheap
beers and so there's this Russian girl
walking she goes do you have a light I
go sounds Chinese but do you have a
light and I go yeah yeah come on yeah
I go and she was like just a Russian
like little kind of f her face or I go
hey what are you doing right now you
want to head up we're about to get some
drinks here at coach my shoe bo pleas
okay and she came with us W and so we're
just you know drinking beers getting
Mees you know getting a buzz our Buzz
going and then afterwards my friend Ace
left me he goes all right I'm out and I
go what the and I go you you you have a
place to stay tonight stay let me finish
and she goes oh okay I my car is parked
my car is parked at the Starbucks
parking lot you will come with me I go
okay and so I should have known like red
flag right away cuz when I walked she
had one of those bigger um Jeeps things
but I noticed I looked in her car and
all it seemed like she was moving out of
her house like all of her belongings
were in there yeah so I go okay she
grabbed a couple things
and we went back to my place mhm so um
it she basically started turning my
place into like a hoarding like storage
place so I noticed that as like days
went by you wait wait wait you were
hanging out with her for days oh yeah I
was Oh I thought this was all the same I
don't even know about this so how many
days moved in oh this is I weeks no
about a week W did you kiss her no no I
was just kind of in the pocket just hope
it was just so you let this lady Russian
Lady walk all over you she walked all
over me yeah and then what ended up
happening she actually like on day two
or three just cuz she like brought her
laptop
in she left and then I noticed that this
guy one night knocked on my door like
yeah I'm here for the car she was trying
to do like car sales at from my place so
Random dudes would come visit like about
the car oh my
God what the
[__] so I go what are you doing who who
is
that dude this is not a good episode cuz
if my girlfriend hears this that's your
past it's your past okay so anyway
um you're
so yeah so one
night she she brought her out her laptop
and she was looking at pictures and like
like family pictures and this kid keeps
popping up
yeah and she starts crying oh no it was
her son and so she's crying like I miss
my
son why am I laughing at this I don't
know so she's crying like looking I miss
myself oh my God and it just just like
the [__] that we have to go through just
all wet like on my shoulder I was just
and then my you know like like I was
like all like I couldn't feel my arm it
was all wet with
you just kept it there the whole time
huh and so you poor James James James
James poor Life Choices so kids if you
ever if you're doing drugs and alcohol
just sober up you know don't don't don't
make the same don't make the same
mistakes James has made congratulations
to the 10
years and I
I I'm so happy for you okay okay I think
that as you're progressing to be as
you're progressing to be a better human
being I find that your brother is
regressing did he tell you about what
happened over the weekend no I would
like to know no what what is you going
to say what happened this does anyone
know what happened over the weekend does
okay what are you going to say before we
even get up I might stop it's the
biggest thing all right well I'm
stopping you why that that has no
business in in this podcast anymore I
feel like it's my right to tell this
story it's my story to tell guess why
what you guys call cuz I [__] put
your poop in a doggy bag didn't I
whoa It's my story now as if I have to
do the cleanup it's my story to
tell I have to know the story now please
tell me tell us Bobby please tell me
your story you tell him story true St so
I get a phone call I get a phone call
he's coming home from from Warner
Brothers and I get a frantic phone call
he's like baby something that's that's
not Neary something so bad just Happ ter
first oh yeah he went to ter
meican which is great food by the way no
there's a new one on anyway and I get a
phone call and he's like babe something
really bad just happened in my head the
first thing it's like oh my God he's
finally run over somebody and like
that's what I because of his driving
yeah cuz he's a wild
driver dude his driving's insane yeah so
then I was like [__] what happened and
he's like I need help I'm downstairs in
the garage and there's poo everywhere
[Music]
and I'm like how is there poo
everywhere it turns out that he was on
the freeway on route to come home stuck
in traffic couldn't make it out of the
exit pulled over into the side of the
freeway climbed over into the back seat
and took [__] in the back
seat you like
Dad that's something dad do
you're just like
Dad you're just like him man was Steve
doing you're just like father I can't
believe it you're just like Dad man
that's something exactly what Dad would
do let me tell you a story dad my dad
was driving he sted his man because he
put uh his merchandise in it and then he
was on some kind of freeway or Highway
and he couldn't stop either but he did
it on a paper plate at
least you did it on the seat he did it
right on the seat disgusting man and
then he comes he comes running upstairs
you're a godd dang animal man you need
help bro and can I tell you what
happened he afterwards he's a beast so
he tells he he comes up and I see his
butt as he W runs into the bathroom and
it's just diarrhea all over his pants so
then I'm thinking he couldn't even take
his [__] pants off it's he it's his
health you know what I mean no we need
to talk no seriously talk his pants and
then into the car seat and then I saided
F listen to this Steve oh
no and then bad and then I said okay
fine I'll take it to the car wash in the
morning but I was like you know what I'm
not going to do it I'm going to have
Jenna do it
because you know Jenna needs the money
and I so I told her you better have
given her $500 she came in in a hazmat
suit she came I swear to God she came
and fully suited it up and but then he
goes it was
$50 dude it's D
50 it was
50 oh Lord and then he said he said I
tried to I tried to clean it with a
spray as as I could so Jenna should be
fine dry so Jenna basically had but then
that's not the worst part on the way
there oh no on the way there Jenna
checked the back seat cuz she was like
something smells really bad are you sure
that he cleaned it with spray and she
goes back there and there's two big
turds that kind of just roll have been
rolling around in the back seat oh it
was camouflaged into the so she then has
to she then has she calls me she's like
oh my God I don't know what to do but
but there's still poo rolling around
back
there and so I she had to pick it up she
had to use her hand she had to Raw hand
it I'm worried about his health what
there's so much he's going to get a
coloscopy there's so much meat Korean
barbecue and just meat that has digested
I know his body I am his
brother he's got I'm just let you know I
believe you know now that you said that
I'm his little brother yeah he's got so
much just story meat bulgogi and steak
and cuz he he eats so good we need to
get him like flushed out okayo let me
tell you my point of view okay okay so
when you told you told me to clean the
car I went down there all right I
cleaned the driver's seat because when I
climbed back in there was [__] all over
the driver's seat and when I look back
there right it looked
like just the back in the day during
Vietnam just like you know you know just
just a war zone M there's [__] all over
the place and I I just thought to myself
I got
$50 Jenna do it and she did it thank you
Jenna but then yeah but here I went to
the store
though that night right and the [__] was
still back there the Poo yeah and the
you know we have a lot guy at the comedy
store and he walks in the car and he
goes dude it smells like [__] in here I
go there is
right and he just left my car there the
whole night in one spot he had to
maneuver all the cars around my car they
wouldn't drive it they wouldn't drive it
yeah yeah so if you don't want people to
drive your car that's a good way to do
it you know what I mean and then also on
top of it um man I'll tell you I'll tell
you my point of view on the in incident
okay yeah so when I you could have went
outside list just listen listen to what
I what now can you listen to my point of
view all right so when I was at teres
which is is Delicious By the way I want
I ordered just a chicken tinga burito
you super nachos no I didn't have super
nachos in a quesadilla I ate it and I I
was I left the restaurant and then in my
head I'm like oh [__] I I she I ordered
her a
salad right so I ran back in I had
already bought it I go do you have the
salad I said to go they go yeah and as
soon as he grabbed I'm like this food I
got to get this to kilah cuz my little
baby honey is starving oh he's going to
put it on me no I'm not going to put it
on you B baby honey but then when I was
walking out of the building I this is
what I
heard right that wasn't even a fart that
was my stomach oh damn that was your
stomach yeah yeah that wasn't even a
fart I farted inside my body oh my God
have you ever done that it just went
yeah I've sucked one I've sucked one in
yeah in my body and and it a little
sweat and I was just like what do I do
now this is as an adult you have these
questions mhm should I get in the car
and just [__] drive home right or
should I just go to the bathroom here
what about going to Terry at Terry yeah
it was in Terry still why did you just
go use her bathroom because she had to
did her salad I would why but it was
also I need to get my salad I I also
just say can I just say this it wasn't
fully like oh I can [__] right now I
could just feel like Brewing up yeah
right for the record baby honey could
have waited a whole hour I know for a
salad I know okay so when you pulled
over
this is she got it wrong okay so I'm not
even on the freeway I'm like kind of
like where you know where Highland is
but this is like 5:00 it's packed it's
packed right and it won't move and all
of a sudden I F A fart that's a fart
nothing came out just fart no but it was
like you know how the that was like the
my opening act like my opening act was
strong First Act yeah and right then I
thought the middle Act was was going to
go up but no but the headliner was there
you'd have time to prepare yeah yeah
there was no middle act a shk no it was
and then the head stuck out right like
that out of the hole like that right
felt solid and I go where's the middle
act yeah you know what I mean a couple
more farts there's no middle act right
so he needs to go up now the headliner
he needs to diarrhea or was it like this
is making me even angrier the fact that
it wasn't diarrhea means that it wasn't
that urgent it was urgent you out of
your mind it was so urgent and let me
just say this right now did you see the
back of my it was a this show this show
it was a variety show oh wow not just
stand up right it wasn't just stand up
it was there was water you know I mean
there was like you know I mean some
other things combo a combo situation
right so I pull over to a residential
area and there's construction happening
on my right side and there you know how
those gigantic construction um trash
containers those gigantic ones I pull
right behind there and I jump in the
back seat I pull my pants down and I you
know all
over okay and the the beginning of it
was the solid part but the end I'm
telling you right now as Jesus as my
witness M it was a liquid
shell like oh like circus yeah circus
liquid okay and I I felt like killing
myself God this smell must have been
horrific it was horrific but he still
brought up my salad with a Chuck full of
[__] in his butt he came home and
there's pool everywhere but he had a
salad at one hand clean dedicated yeah
have you you haven't done that ever huh
I've done it all the time i' she's seen
me poo on houses yeah on house walls
like he will actually just bend over
shoot it like Point his butt at a wall
and then
spray she saw me do that and on
someone's like gardinas yeah
yeah we need to need go to the doctor we
got to we got to fix it maybe maybe not
I mean his health man you know no I'm
serious yeah like are you're being real
serious right now I'm being serious so
you let me ask you something what do you
think is going on with me your your diet
it's all meat you think I eat all meat
no veggies no h that's interesting it's
potato vegetable yes it is I eat that
too I'm just saying you cuz you have so
much money you you make a good living
okay you can eat Korean bar everyone
listening I do okay thank you he could
afford eating out all the time right
uhuh I don't he doesn't go to like Soup
Plantation does
he how is Sloop Plantation like the
healthy spot I'm it's just not just
veggies cucumbers Tomatoes you know what
I mean veggies what did I eat yesterday
meat I did eat meat smoke walk us
through we to smoke it yesterday so
yesterday I woke up and uh your little
Filipino niece is staying with us
Juliana great oh yeah she's great and um
so I took her to Warner Brothers and I
go let's go to the smok house was right
next to it and I had a prime rib so good
damn right you did yeah I but I had
fried zucchini ch right fried zucchini
lik fried stuff yeah but zucchini deep
fried like that is not healthy sweetie
it totally just eliminates the outer
part is unhealthy but the inner part is
healthy no it's not you've already taken
away all like deep frying it takes away
all of the the good stuff oh anyway then
what else did I have then we the
artichoke the Grilled artichoke that was
good this is all at the same place yeah
at the same place so I had a prime rib
with a potato garlic bread and then last
night I had bosanova I had a fried
chicken patty fried deep fried no it was
a chicken like you know frieden fried
deep fried deep fried with batter fries
that's my concern is he's you guys are
doing well he's doing well that's the
only thing that could take him down is
his health that's why I don't go out to
eat with you guys anymore so we're not
going to eat after this because I just
can't we got a we got to guess I got to
fil did they text back not yet yeah I I
have an episode I have to text but I
can't afford to to eat as indulgently as
him so I don't go out to eat with him I
just make my own food at home cuz that
shit's not healthy could he do the inter
intermittent fasting do you think you
know what he actually doesn't cuz I was
doing that every Sunday I was doing it
every Sunday I would not eat for 24
hours Gil that's his that's not his
problem cuz he actually won't eat for 16
hours but in those eight hours he eats
real pure garbage Taco Bell like I won't
eat 12 hours and I'll eat a fat burger
with fried egg and chili yeah damn then
my body goes crazy and straight into
like a Strawberry Shortcake and then I
go right to sleep so that stuff is in my
body when I'm sleeping yeah he actually
has a big meal before sleep yeah
mhm it's not good guys it's not good and
um you know very
concerning is he sleeping okay or no no
today he slept at like 10 o'clock in the
morning in the morning yeah and have a
10:00 in the call time tomorrow morning
too oh gosh I mean yeah he's
self-sabotaging I I I I you know how do
stay out of it I mean do you what time
do you go to sleep um like one two two
three that's better what were you doing
oh you were playing Red Dead Redemption